the nfl 100 all-time team series that
i've been telling you about for weeks
and months
episode five of six will be friday night
at eight eastern time involving the wide
receivers
last week with the tight ends and
offensive linemen
um it it it was my favorite moment of
the entire
um series to date that's aired and
just to set the stage tony gonzalez of
the tight end group is sitting there
anthony munoz the offensive lineman
sitting right in front of me and
belichick and chris collinsworth to my
right as they have been for the entire
series
and we're talking about the next two
coaches to be named the all-time team
list
paul brown of the bengals but before
that vince lombardi is named
which led me to ask a question of
belichick
that everybody's been wanting to ask him
i think
uh and i took a shot here and the
belichick who's been so effusive
and uh passionate disappeared
take a look okay here's a good question
and joining us on the show from football
night in america chris collins for
sunday night football i forgot how funny
that was i forgot about that one that's
great i mean you turned him here like
you knew you were going to get shut down
but i asked
you knew what was going to happen oh it
was great
that was like the lawrence taylor stop
i'm telling you because i'll be honest
with you i haven't seen the last two
shows we've been trying to crank out
all the stuff we're doing on sunday
night but the the lawrence taylor stuff
it just fractured me i mean i literally
could not i had to get myself back
together after watching that
guy he was he was so funny he was and he
was only slated to stay for one segment
too and he stayed for several of them
including the joe green
segment that chris i mean and and this
was a moment where
i think you and i kind of shared a look
with each other too
um that at least i recall this is that
belichick asked the first question of
joe green
and and i thought to myself he goes i
got to ask you something and i thought
in my head i'm like okay here comes a
question about the steel curtain or
about chuck noll instead he asked him
about his coke commercial and i'm like
who who is this guy i'm like right
i i think that was the biggest takeaway
and i thought it would be
after we finished all the shows is that
this was a belichick i think that maybe
you and i had seen
at various times away from press
conferences away from
you know whatever production meetings or
whatever
uh that there's this human element to
this guy
um and but it it came out a lot
more than i even expected um
i thought he would be really guarded and
the thing that made it really
interesting for me was and and i think
surprised him
he really can be effusive if you've
heard one of his
wednesday press conferences where he's
talking about the star players for
other teams it's pretty effusive right i
mean he he goes on and on about you know
this is the greatest guy ever
but i think he really got surprised with
the way that the players were talking
about
him uh and what an honor it was to be in
the room with him and what
a incredible career i i think it was
emmett who
at one point said well you're talking
about me
you're the one that holds all the state
you know what i mean it's like and i
think it almost
that part of it i think caught him a
little bit off guard
and opened him up in a way that maybe he
wouldn't have otherwise
i saw the same thing too chris in the
way again that the nfl films people who
are so terrific at what they do
set things up with that monument board
where everybody had their tile placed
when they got
you know inducted for the lack of a
better phrase or named
belichick was sitting right in front of
that and i remember dion
i think it was either in a commercial
break or he may have even said it on the
air
dion's like looking at bill as he's
looking at the wall and he's looking at
bill it's like what are you doing here
and the fact that bill was there to
welcome them in for a lot of guys who
got in the pro football hall of fame and
thought that they
may never have that feeling again of
accomplishment
and and humility got it again and i
watched
we watched that together in person chris
yeah and it was interesting i think it
was dion who at one point
said something like okay this is great
but now we want to know who's in the
starting lineup
you can't narrow it down enough for
these competitive guys that always want
to be considered the best
um but it was it was it was really great
i mean and the way they're busting each
other's chops
uh if you remember ray lewis referred to
his
his grandfather told him he has to watch
this player right
and it probably came out in about five
or six
stories um that we were doing and that
was just
i don't know why it just ended up that
was the way he opened his comments about
other players
as he was going on and and at one point
uh lawrence taylor was sitting next to
ray and ray
says you want to know who told me that i
had to watch whoever it was that plays
that
and lt had the greatest deadpan of all
time he looked over at him he goes
let me guess your grandpa
i mean none of us could get it back
together again i don't know how they
edited that thing i don't know how it
came out exactly
but oh my goodness we were and there
were moments when i laughed as hard as
i've laughed all right here on that show
agreed i mean and and belichick telling
the story about lt being late to a
defensive meeting and
and he basically told parcells
afterwards just hey just to let you know
lt was late for five minutes and parcel
said why'd you start the meeting with
him
why didn't you wait on him that was that
was amazing but then there was another
moment too
chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen show that struck me you were the
one who started the conversation with ed
reed
about a play that you saw peyton manning
got completely
fooled because ed had gone broken a
tendency
all year long that he had studied
the of manning to and prepared to break
his own tendency to fool peyton manning
and belichick stopped you mid-story to
finish
the play that had nothing to do with the
patriots he knew
what you guys were talking about you
know why because
he actually i think they played the next
week
or something like that um and
i mean it really was one of the hall of
fame plays so
you know i think people knew what they
were talking about a little bit
but that was the thing with bill is this
you know i feel like you can and i can
take these conversations to a certain
level
but at some point somebody who's
actually
game planned against these players right
that's a whole different level of what
you're willing to do or not do
and that was part of the magic of that
show chris collinsworth here on the rich
eisen chart let's talk some sunday night
football
you have seen virtually every team
that's in the mix for
uh a super bowl you've seen new orleans
without breeze that was a fascinating
night with teddy bridgewater
uh you also saw uh one of the few flex
games i mean everything's been virtually
almost
the way it was scheduled uh with san
francisco taking care of business you
were
what witnessed new england lose its
first game of the year
with the ravens the best team that
you've seen with your own two eyes
through 15 weeks would be
which chris baltimore
um and and as much as i want to talk
about lamar
jackson and i think that that's the
story
um i also think that anybody can tell
you about lamar jackson right
that this is a team that um
that i mean he does spectacular things
and
uh john harbaugh's decision
to go there with him i mean you think
about
that decision and everybody you know now
goes oh yeah well we had lamar we know
you did because he would laugh at the
number 32
right so but he basically
committed his career to lamar jackson
he he effectively said i understand i am
going to have to change
we are going to have to change
everything we do
everything we do is going to have to be
different if we play with lamar jackson
we've got to commit to a different
running style we got to go get a big
back like a mark ingram we've got to go
you know we've got to find a speed
receiver so when they try to play
man-to-man coverage against us
you know so they go out and they draft
hollywood brown and you know and
right down the list so everything's
going to be different and
and that commitment and he told us the
story of the decision and we're finally
i mean they're
literally going at it in the draft room
and they're just debating back and forth
and he finally goes
let's do it right and it was about that
simple
and from that moment i i think that you
know i was certainly at their high end
of hopes that they were gonna
they were thinking that you know this is
gonna work out but i don't think any of
them could have imagined how quickly
this thing has become the phenomenon
that it is but i'll say this rich
as good as he's been and he's been
fantastic um
this is a this is a team of men
i'm telling you right now when you talk
about
physical football you put orlando brown
and marshall yonda and ronnie stanley
with mark
ingram behind him and if you were not
sure even that ingram's gonna get the
ball
and maybe here comes lamar jackson on
the edge and maybe there goes hollywood
brown
but the thing that impresses me more
than anything else is when it's time to
go toe-to-toe and pray we're getting
there right we're almost
in playoff season bad weather all that
kind of stuff
when it's time to go toe-to-toe this
team physically will match up with
anybody
well then the question is is who has the
best chance to
maybe beat them or prevent them from
getting to the super bowl and i kind of
go back and forth on this chris
collinsworth here on the rich eisen show
is it a team that's already seen him
before
so you can you can draw upon an
experience it's not a first time
experience you
know how fast lamar jackson is you do
know what this offense looks like and
you don't have to simulate it with
somebody who clearly isn't the real
mccoy in some sort of scout team or
is it somebody that does have the
physical firepower
offensive firepower and defensive
strength to beat them in a first time
shot what do you think
um i i know who you're talking about
what you're talking about
and i i agree with you but maybe not the
team that you
think i think okay obviously the
patriots are the team that comes to mind
first right
so they the patriots did not play that
well defensively that night
and the strength of the patriots is in
their secondary
that's what they do best their coverage
skills are
clearly what they do best and we know
belichick
a second time around the thing i hear
complaints about all the time is
no matter how smart a coach you are you
can't get ready for
for these guys in one week you just
can't
there's too many things that are
different i mean i can remember watching
my son play at notre dame and they go
play navy with the triple option
well they're only doing it every once a
year you know i mean
and meanwhile navy's been practicing
this thing for the last
50 years uh and being very good at it
the team that impressed me and surprised
me the most
honestly was san francisco uh if you
remember the day they went up there and
you're thinking okay we know lamar and
we know
ingram we know that ravens can run the
ball and the weather conditions were
horrible and it was raining the the
the 49ers were just coming off a big
game had to travel across the country
had to play at one o'clock which is 10
a.m for a west coast team and usually
those teams don't play well in that
situation
and played them down to the wire and
played in my physical
game defensive matched up pretty darn
well
against lamar and the offense i i
came out it was the first time i really
came out of a game believing
in the 49ers and of course what they did
against new orleans
and then the other thing that always
comes up for me is everybody's going to
say yeah but you know right they lost to
atlanta
but how many times do we see a team play
their best game of the year
which was in new orleans no question for
san francisco and turn around and can't
get close to that effort the next week
because you spent the whole week
at restaurants and bars there by telling
you you're the greatest thing ever
because of the same time it's just it's
a matter of fact so
uh you know i i still think san
francisco is the team to really watch
yeah they also didn't have six defensive
starters because man i mean talk about
attrition to go from baltimore to
new orleans i mean that is no joke uh
chris collins here on the rich eyes show
two more questions for you
so the team that uh you think maybe not
be in the top two seeds radar screen
uh nobody's talking about uh green bay
even they are a top two
seed uh kansas city has improved
defensively throughout the last few
weeks they had t
sizzle now give me a team that you think
can make a run here and win it all yeah
chris kansas city they um i i just got
finished uh watching their tape
obviously and
uh i thought mahomes look like mvp my
homes again
i it was it was really one of the best
games i've seen all year from a player
um it played in the snow and the weather
and all that stuff just
added to it but he's starting to he made
one throw in that game
that um that i i i played it back
25 times so he was looking left looking
left looking left
um and nobody was there and all of a
sudden he started his throwing motion
as he was turning his body back to the
right
uh and his tight end on not kelsey
but the other tight end 81 and i'll
think of his name in a second
um but it comes is standing there on the
plate belt
over on the sideline he's standing over
on the sideline
uh and and i'm telling you this throwing
motion
started as he was turning in that
direction there was
no way he could have seen him there was
no way he could have known he was wide
open on the sidelines
and yet somehow that throwing motion
just started all at once and i i can't
wait
to talk to him and say how did how did
that happen just explain to me i'm going
to show you this play in slow motion
and when he starts making those kinds of
plays and he starts running the way that
he is
and he starts sliding like he's a real
baseball player instead of just
trying to survive and not hurt his knee
again i just see some
of that magic and defensively uh the
thing that people probably won't know is
this
spagnola has put in a little bella check
in
about every defense known to man and
they play
they basically change coverage it seems
like on every single snap of the ball
so while that may not look good early in
the season
late in the year that sort of
versatility and ability to change
midstream is going to pay dividends yeah
blake bell i believe is who you're
referring to
and it's chiefs and bears on sunday
night football
and then i'm i'm assuming you're making
arrangements for seattle right
you guys planning on game 256 being san
francisco at seattle for the last game
yeah i mean that's the way it looks to
me nice yeah i think that's the one
we're open for
exactly now last one for you chris i
will say this and i don't mean to
um embarrass you but al loves you man um
and
um uh it's been just such a pleasure of
mine since moving to los angeles to get
to know al michaels and
and so when i told him i was doing the
show the nfl 100 all-time team show with
you he's just like wait to
wait till you get next to him and you
were dynamite
on this show chris you were amazing and
i i knew you had the ability to
uh converse and talk uh in a studio
setting but the thing that really hit me
and
and i think there's a lot of folks who
obviously have known you as a
broadcaster for as long as you have for
successfully as long as you have
you had an amazing uh experience playing
against
a lot of these guys who were named to
the all-time team and paul brown
as well do you have a good story you
just want to leave
everyone with about one of the people
who have been uh announced i mean mel
blunt somebody
that you played against that that uh
left you uh impressed or literally
physically if not
uh emotionally an impression upon you
chris
they all left a lot of impressions on me
but
probably uh jack lambert after i caught
a ball
one time over the middle in my rookie
year
and i came walking
i i'm sitting there and jack sort of
gave me the knee to the groin and the
elbow to the chest and
grabbed my face mask and gave me one
others collinsworth if you
ever come over to middle again i'll kill
you
and um i was like all right so i kind of
staggered my feet and
walked back over the huddle and anthony
munoz is over there
and i got just a big smile on my face
and anthony said
thank you smiling about man jack lambert
almost killed you over there
i said i know but he knew my name man
exactly knew my name
oh i mean it was a thrill for me we got
a chance to
uh to sit amongst greatness
uh you were your usual fantastic self
you know what it felt rich it just felt
casual didn't it
yeah it felt casual it felt neat it was
really cool it was a great feeling to it
all
um i agree it really just everyone was
left buzzing talking about how special
uh the shoot was and how obviously nfl
films would have six months in an edit
bay to make it work
we all knew how great it was and again
that lambert story that
i think lent wasn't lambert the one that
belichick started talking about how
lambert got his first
shot uh in college because the guy in
front of him on the depth chart left to
be a uh
security for the rolling stones i mean
wasn't right
i mean like again belichick were like
what are you talking like is he giving
us rolling stones football trivia that
was amazing
the thing that i came away with was man
wouldn't you like to be
one of the jimmy johnsons of the world
that got to go on his boat
after the season when he was really just
had a beer in his hand
and totally out of gear and just sitting
and
bs around and telling football stories
with and
it would be great but the other thing
that i came around
away from that whole thing was
i'm really old man i mean i literally
either grew up watching as a kid
playing against broadcasting
almost everybody on that board i mean
there was there you know other than the
ones that belichick brought back in
black and white
i mean i really had a firsthand
recollection
of almost everybody on that team and
that was what struck me more than
anything else man you are old
yeah you know what but i i took it as
just you being a perfect analyst to uh
sit next to belichick and for me uh to
enjoy sitting next to you for that it
was awesome
uh and i appreciate this call too have a
great call with al sunday night in
chicago and beyond we'll be
chatting down the road chris thanks bud
good time to be here you got it at
collinsworth pff don't forget about
uh everything that he does with pro
football focus he owns it
and he brings it every single sunday
night on nbc chris collinsworth here on
the rich eisen show
for more of the rich eisen show tune to
audience channel 239 on directv
for free on br live or download the rich
eisenshow app